hat ein Bundeswehr Mitarbeiter für
Russland spioniert am Mittwoch hat die
Bundesanwaltschaft in Koblenz einen
offizierfest nehmen lassen der unter dem
Verdacht steht Informationen an den
russischen Geheimdienst weitergeleitet
zu haben dazu hat sich jetzt auch
Innenministerin väser geäußert und sagte
seit dem russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine habe die Bedrohung durch
Spionage
Desinformationskampagnen und
Cyberangriffe eine andere Dimension
erhalten was ist genau passiert
offiziert Thomas H soll der russischen
Botschaft mehrmals eine Zusammenarbeit
angeboten haben und in mindestens einem
Fall soll er auch Informationen
weitergegeben haben darüber und die
aktuellen neuesten Entwicklungen können
wir jetzt sprechen mit dem
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden des
parlamentarischen kontrollkrieg Gremiums
Roderich kieserwetter als bei uns hallo
schönen guten Tag Herr Kiesewetter hallo
Grüße
der Mann der hat im beschaffungsdienst
der Bundeswehr gearbeitet da geht es um
sensible Informationen zu Waffensystem
zuständig für die gesamte Ausrüstung der
Bundeswehr ist das Beschaffungsamt weiß
man da schon mehr welche von diesen
sensiblen Informationen da jetzt
möglicherweise weitergegeben worden sind
das ist uns noch nicht bekannt im
Parlament der Generalbundesanwalt
ermittelt aber durch die Art und Weise
wie hier vorgegangen wird auch durch den
Generalbundesanwalt gehe ich davon aus
dass es ein gravierender Fall ist ein
gravierender Fall und hat Offizier
Thomas H da von sich ausgehandelt von
sich aus ist er also darauf zugegangen
auf die russische Botschaft oder hat
sich möglicherweise auch Russland an ihn
gewarnt was sind denn dazu für Details
bekannt
wenn wir den Bundesjustizminister folgen
und was wir gestern veröffentlicht hat
dass es sich hier offensichtlich um
jemanden handelt mit Thomas hart ja sich
selbst angeboten hat der mehrfach
versucht hat über einen Generalkonsulat
in Bonn und über die Botschaft in Berlin
die russische Botschaft Verbindung mit
Russland aufzunehmen also jemand der als
Überzeugungstäter handelt der aus innere
Motivation sich auf die Seite des
russischen Aggressors gegen die Ukraine
also auf die Seite des
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieges Russland
gegen die Ukraine gestellt hat eine
bewusste Entscheidung und trotzdem fragt
man sich natürlich wie kann aber so
etwas passieren müssten Mitarbeiter
MitarbeiterInnen und so sensiblen
Bereichen nicht besser überprüft werden
ja es gibt Sicherheitsüberprüfungen in
der vergangenen Woche wurde ja deutlich
das über 70.000
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen allein bei der
Bundeswehr noch in der Warteschleife
sind hier muss man moderner werden auch
mehr offene Quellen nutzen wie im
Internet und ähnliche Dinge aber es ist
eine andere Baustelle viel gravierender
ist dass es offensichtlich eine Reihe
von Angehörigen gibt seit 2015 ist das
der vierte oder der fünfte Fall im
bundeswehrumfeld wo sich Angehörige der
Bundeswehr als selbstanbieter an
russische Einrichtungen gewendet haben
der letzte Fall war dieser Herr G aus
Düsseldorf der zu einer mehrjährigen
Strafe verurteilt wurde also haben wir
es hier mit überzeugungstättern zu tun
die unabhängig von der
Sicherheitsüberprüfung Vorgehen ferner
kommt noch dazu dass eine große afd-nähe
herrscht auch hier in dem vorliegenden
Fall von Thomas H haben wir es zumindest
mit einem Sympathisanten der AFD zu tun
einer Partei die russische operative
verbreitet deren Abgeordnete im
russischen Fernsehen auftreten die
behaupten dass es in Deutschland keine
freien gleichen allgemeinen und
unmittelbaren Wahlen gibt die sagen
Deutschland sei eine Diktatur und das
sind Abgeordnete aber zu diesen
Abgeordneten Zielen auch mehrere frühere
Bundeswehrangehörige darunter auch
Stabsoffiziere wie ein Major ein
Oberstleutnant ein Oberst aber eben auch
ein General und dieser general
verbreitet ähnlich Russland und
kritische Auffassungen wie ein früherer
Generalinspektor der SPD-Mitglied ist
und sehr offen sagt Russland sei unser
wichtigster Nachbar und unsere gesamte
Politik gegenüber osteuropäischen
Ländern müssen wir durch die russische
Brille sehen fatal also gibt es
Vorbilder für solche russlandfreunde
auch in etablierten Parteien bzw erst
recht in der AFD aber eben auch in
anderen Parteien und dabei auch
Aushängeschilder wie ein früherer
Generalinspektor und das stimmt schon
sehr nachdenklich und macht deutlich
wenn 20% die Bevölkerung in Deutschland
rechtsradikal oder rechtsradikalaffin
sind dann macht das auch vor den
Sicherheitsbehörden nicht halt und
deswegen müssen die
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen verschärft
werden aber auch das Gespräch mit den
Mitarbeitenden gesucht werden und
klargemacht werden dass eine
Mitgliedschaft in der AFD oder eine
Annäherung an der AFD beispielsweise der
Grund wäre solche Sicherheitsdienste zu
verlassen und andere staatliche Stellen
beruflich aufzusuchen sie haben es
gerade selbst gesagt es ist nicht der
erste Fall von mutmaßlicher Spionage für
Russland auch den gab es schon mal in
einer Regierungsbehörde in Deutschland
im Dezember war ein Mitarbeiter des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes festgenommen
worden der einem russischen
Nachrichtendienst Staatsgeheimnisse
verraten haben soll jetzt fragt man sich
aber natürlich das war jetzt da nicht
der erste Fall wie will die Deutsche
Spionageabwehr denn darauf künftig
reagieren dass das eben nicht wieder
passiert
also der BND hat hier sehr intensive
Vorsorgemaßnahmen getroffen bis hin zur
Frage wie man mit Handys und
Bildschirmen und so weiter umgeht und
hier
Sicherheitsverfahren entwickelt aber das
ändert ja nichts daran dass Menschen
solche Einstellungen haben und deshalb
kommt es darauf an dass man
entsprechende Erklärungen abverlangt von
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern in
sensiblen Bereichen aber auch im Bereich
der politischen Bildung einfach deutlich
macht dass Russland Nähe nicht vereinbar
ist mit einer Mitarbeit in
Sicherheitsorganisationen wie
Nachrichtendiensten den Polizeien der
Länder des Bundes des Bundeskriminalamts
beispielsweise oder eben unsere
Bundeswehr
und würden Sie sagen hier bei uns in
Deutschland hat die Bedrohung durch den
russischen Geheimdienst in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren auch noch mal
zugenommen
die Bedrohung war ich schon immer da es
geht ja so weit dass man mal aufklären
muss warum mein früherer Bundeskanzler
sich für nordstream 1 eingesetzt hat
warum zur Hochzeit des Krieges gegen die
krime und die Ostukraine 2014/15 ein
Nord Stream 2 Abkommen getroffen wurde
hier gibt es ein Buch die Moskau
connection von bingener und vener das
erste Hinweise gibt dass wir hier noch
sehr viel aufzuarbeiten haben in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland aber in der
Tat seit Kriegsbeginn haben die
russischen Vorgehensweisen massiv
zugenommen wir müssen uns bewusst sein
dass wir als Deutschland Kriegsziel
Russland sind wir sind nicht
Kriegspartei aber Kriegsziel weil
Russland alles tun wird dass die
Unterstützung aus Deutschland für die
Ukraine abnimmt und wir sehen es ja auch
mit welcher Verzagtheit wir Monate
gebraucht haben die viele Tausende Opfer
verursacht haben das Kampfpanzer
geliefert wurden und jetzt die ganze
Debatte und Taurus die mithelfen würde
dass die Ukraine die Krim befreien kann
auch hier extreme Zurückhaltung all dies
halte ich für sehr gravierend und das
muss aufgearbeitet werden es geht
schlichtweg darum dass wir unsere
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
schützen und stärken müssen und uns
Bewusstsein müssen das Russland den
Zusammenhalt dieser Bevölkerung
zersetzen will das geht hin bis zur
Aufforderung an die Ukraine Ukraine dass
sie keine Zukunft mehr in ihrem Land
haben und dass sie lieber jetzt als
später das Land verlassen weil wenn Sie
jetzt noch nach Mitteleuropa kommen
hätten sie feste Unterkünfte wenn sie
erst den Krieg im Winter kommen dann
gibt's nur noch Zelte also hier wird
bewusst mit Desinformationen Propaganda
gearbeitet und deswegen müssen wir
unsere Gesellschaft auch die
Bundesregierung drängen dass sie besser
informiert das deutlich gesagt wird
Russland ist als Kriegspartei jemand der
uns schaden will und wir dürfen hier
nicht dieser russischen Propaganda auf
den Leim gehen sondern müssen
selbstbewusster unsere eigene
strategische Kultur von Frieden und
Freiheit von transatlantischer
Zusammenarbeit und europäischer unter
Nachbarschaft ja vorantreiben und und
auch vorleben was sind also jetzt ganz
konkrete nächste Schritte die Folgen
werden sowohl für den Verdächtigen für
Thomas Haar der sitzt in uhaft es gab
eine Hausdurchsuchung aber eben auch
insgesamt also um sich gegen Spionage
wehren zu können was sind ganz konkrete
nächste Schritte was können Sie uns
darüber sagen
also wir sind ja immer einen Schritt
hinten dran weil diejenigen die Spionage
Sabotage oder Zersetzung betreiben wird
die Geschwindigkeit bestimmen den Ort
die Menschen mit denen sie sprechen ein
erster Schritt ist auf jeden Fall die
Sensibilisierung unserer eigenen Leute
dass sie nicht auf russische Propaganda
hereinfallen dass wir aber auch sehr
deutlich sagen eine Mitgliedschaft oder
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD ist
unvereinbar mit einer Mitarbeit im BND
im Verfassungsschutz im Militärischen
Abschirmdienst oder in anderen
Sicherheitsbehörden beispielsweise auch
in der Bundeswehr es muss unvereinbar
sein und dann müssen diese Leute eben
ihre Berufe überdenken dann gibt es noch
einen ganz gravierenden Punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte das berührt den
Koalitionsvertrag im Koalitionsvertrag
ist die Rede von einer
überwachungsgesamtrechnung betrieben von
FDP und Grünen die quasi der Bevölkerung
eine Bilanz aufzeigen wollen wie viel
funküberwachungsmaßnahmen gab es wie
viel Innenraum Überwachung wie viele
Observationen auf die 83 Millionen
Einwohner das ist natürlich Humbug weil
eine überwachungsgesamtrechnung immer
abhängig ist von der Bedrohung und
deswegen brauchen wir eine
bedrohungsgesamtrechnung und die
Bundesregierung muss hier Umsteuern in
der SPD erkennen wir hier bereits
mögliche Schritte in diese Richtung weil
die SPD inzwischen erkennt dass die
Union gar nicht so falsch liegt wenn wir
fordern statt eine überwachungs eine
bedrohungsgesamtrechnung zu machen aber
es geht auch darum dass wir die
technischen Möglichkeiten unserer
Dienste verbessern dass die Dienste ja
ich muss es zuspitzen Frau jung
die Bundesregierung rühmt sich dass sie
die am besten überwachten am besten
kontrollierten Nachrichtendienste der
Welt hat ich würde mir wünschen dass die
Bundesregierung sich rühmt die
leistungsfähigsten Nachrichtendienste
der Welt zu haben die im rechtsstaatlich
legalen Rahmen operieren deswegen müssen
unsere Nachrichtendienste deutlich
besser ausgestattet werden und auch mit
einem gewissen Grundvertrauen dass sie
bestimmte Dinge leisten dazu gehört auch
dass wir ein technischen
aufklärungsdienst brauchen der alle drei
Nachrichtendienste entsprechend
unterstützt dass wir unser Personal das
dort arbeitet noch besser ausleben und
das wir die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen so machen dass unsere
Nachrichtendienste auch in der Lage sind
wesentliche Informationen zu beschaffen
und rasch auszuwerten aber ein Großteil
des Personals ist in ist eben in der
Kontrolle der Dienste gebunden und das
verhindert eben nicht Fälle wie diesen
Karsten l von dem sie vorhin Sprachen
aus dem BMW und in den Streitkräften
müssen wir mit Blick auf die politische
Bildung und auf die vorgesetzt Fürsorge
noch etwas anderes ändern beispielsweise
die europäische Arbeitszeitrichtlinie
ich kann in Kriegszeiten nicht mit einer
41 Stunden Woche attraktiver
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen weil ich
schlichtweg die Leute in der knappen
Arbeitszeit überfordere also auch da
müssen wir ran und etwas
unbürokratischer arbeitszeitfragen
klären auch mit entsprechenden
zeitlichen und finanziellen Ausgleich
fordert der stellvertretende Vorsitzende
des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums
Roderich Kiesewetter von der
Oppositionspartei CDU vielen Dank Herr
Kiesewetter vielen Dank Frau jung und
alles gut